el congreso peruano insiste en hablar
por el pueblo pero el pueblo dice otra
cosa así lo reclamaron en las calles
cientos de personas que salieron a
protestar por la destitución del
exmandatario martín vizcarra un día
después de que el poco conocido
presidente del congreso peruano manuel
merino asumiera su lugar
interinamente
bueno porque indignación que sentimos
todos al menos nosotros de como el
congreso
tan expresamente una vacancia por
incapacidad moral el congreso hablando
de capacidad moral por favor cuántas
congresistas están investigados ahora en
medio de la carrera de merino por
juramentar a su gabinete para sacar el
país de una nueva fase de inestabilidad
política
el silencio inunda los partidos que
apoyaron la medida mientras las críticas
estallan entre los legisladores que la
rechazan la división más de las calles
al congreso y la desconexión se pone en
medio de la brecha entre el congreso y
la gente es anterior a esta crisis y en
las dos crisis anteriores en general la
clase política en la que el congreso de
parte esté libre desconectada en la
gente nos vemos en todos los estudios
que se han realizado y las encuestas de
opinión pública las protestas no cesan
desde la destitución de vizcarra por
presunta corrupción
merino el tercer presidente de perú en
cuatro años seguirá en el poder hasta
julio cuando asuma el nuevo mandatario
que escojan los peruanos en las
elecciones de abril